I watched your video on Enoch's two protein, it seemed like that is an early marker of cancer,
is there a test you can use to monitor this protein? If so, it makes sense to use to track the
progress and toward revision. There used to be a test to mark this, that's one of the reasons why
I created that video, there used to be a test, and there was supposed to be another test coming out
that you could test for that. It just got to be too expensive, and the lab did not proceed with
further creation of that test. We got to be a couple thousand dollars to run the test, so
they scrapped it. It's just a high level, high degree of education that would have to take place
in the functional medicine community to get doctors to order that test, especially at that
price, which is going to continue in business. Unfortunately, there's not that the present time
test to mark the monitor Enoch's two expression, so that's what the test measured is, the expression
of the Enoch two protein, because the Enoch two protein blocks a poptosis, and it stimulates glycolysis,
so increased levels of Enoch's two protein, with somebody asking the answer. There is ways to
think I talked about that video. There is ways to naturally block this protein, and that's actually
the mechanism of a chiant pepper. So chiant pepper is such a good product for cardio. There's a product
that's good for both cardiovascular and for cancer, so they were sent a couple of minutes ago,
that there's a lot of products that are collaborative in cancer that you would use for cardiovascular
and vice versa. The chiant pepper is one that's going to cross the board. That's why you should be
in hot sauce, other food. I say that because I grow a lot of chiant peppers in our garden,
and make a lot of contents. So chiant peppers, great for that, so something you could do to treat
this out, you've been done here in Lagos.